I'll be honest with you guys I've been
thinking about getting a joker tattoo I
actually was thinking of getting this
one because I think it looks really cool
it's like the Joker comes up he's like
you know what boom how about those
tattoos that's right guys the first
official picture of Jared Leto as the
Joker has hit the Internet which means
all the naysayers are going to get on
their cameras and start talking and
hopefully be proven wrong but as the
Joker is my favorite character of all
days like Joker Darth Vader they're the
two I will go ahead and take a leap and
say the Joker is the most iconic comic
book villain of all time yeah got more
than a couple things to say about this
first of all no matter what I say in
this video just know and remember that I
still have faith in Jared Leto's ability
to betray the Joker how the director
wants to do it how the studio wants to
do it that's a different story
I still think Jared Leto's the man I'm
hopeful that's all I can say that being
said does he look crazy yeah he
absolutely looks crazy feel like you got
the crazy eyes dude I'm glad the Joker
has the crazy eyes he's got the green
hair Joker green hair so you look at the
hair alone you're like alright they're
going back to a comic book Joker you see
everything from the hairline down you're
like guess not no one can argue this is
an interesting take on the Joker the
dude
straight-up looks like a crate it looks
like a really skeezy shady guy in some
dark corner of a rave selling ecstasy to
kid true story I was in the mall and I
was like 18 years old I was wearing like
a black coat these kids came up to me
they were like hey is your name spider
I was like well it's they were like uh
nothing and they just left pretty sure
that's to do they were looking for
that's what I told my friend I was like
this looks like a really cool Joker
cosplay like if I saw this dude at Comic
Con I'd be like yeah cool all right you
got the Joker fan thing going you know
you got the tattoos I say you're a joker
fan you got the face makeup interesting
tag on the jug or do good work that's my
problem with the tattoos that the
tattoos look like it's something that a
Joker fan would get not something that
the Joker would have I do like the mouth
tattoo on his arm because you know if
Batman's doing his cape thing he's being
all Batman Joker can be like oh it's
like this creepy mouth right there and
that would look really cool almost
mockery so I see the potential in that
one the skull jester tattoo I think
that's fine I'm like alright yeah okay I
can deal with that things that make me
go what on earth is the grille like why
on earth does he have that why are his
teeth like that that's one of those
things you look at they're like oh
they're trying to make it some new edgy
Joker attaches I really have a
with or the fact that it says
hahahahahahaha like all over his body
why would the Joker have that on his
body that's something he writes on a
wall if he's just like in the moment if
he's in the moment if he's messing with
Batman if he wants Batman and know he
was there's his message you leave there
are a few other reasons he might write
that somewhere on his body though it's
like I don't get that that's like I said
it's like something that a Joker fan
would tattoo on their body plus if it's
like one of those moments of passion
thing was like hi writing ha ha ha
everywhere because you're just so insane
with passion at the moment how was that
passion actually going to hold if he's
like yeah what a tattoo yeah go boom
tattoo me ha ha ha right there
you
okay passions got passions gone yeah a
passion all right it's just hot like
that moment wouldn't last long enough
for him to get a tattoo and the fact
that it says damaged on his head who
wrote that did he go to a tattoo parlor
he's like I want you to write damaged on
my forehead I feel like that's like
something someone at Arkham would hold
the Joker down and then write damaged on
his head I don't know why Joker would do
that and the fact that the concept is
the Joker wrote damaged on his head and
tattooed it on his head or had
hahahahaha on his body it's like they're
like we need to show you from first
glance at the Joker's crazy we need to
put in your face it he's crazy it's like
let his work speak for it man let's just
watch him be crazy this is like
hopefully it's one of those scenarios
where a good book has a really flashy
cover that it didn't need another
question is how often are we actually
going to see the tattoos really we're
going to see the tattoos in one or two
scenes and then after that he's just
gonna wear a suit we're never gonna see
the tattoos anymore I feel like I'm
gonna forget the tattoos if Jared Leto's
performance is overriding the tattoos
and his clothes are physically covering
them I saw a couple pictures where it
looks like Jared Leto is wearing a suit
it's a white suit or a white ish suit it
looks like it's more or less aiming to
capture the Dark Knight Returns fail
this Batman V Superman Justice League
universe if they're making all there are
things that I was lawyer that doesn't
look like it's going to be good that I'm
now going nah that looks pretty good and
vice-versa
and this is yet another element living
up to that tradition to be honest with
you guys as a huge Joker fan I was
hoping they would go back to the comic
book Joker and this is the thing about
the Joker he's such a diverse character
you can play him many different ways and
portray him many different ways all of
which can be accurate I know it sounds
like I'm just bitching about this and I
don't mean for it to sound like that
like I said I think Jared Leto can pull
off a great Joker I'm interested to see
them betray a character that is so
diverse that could be portrayed at so
many different angles who looks like
that I want to see what they do with
that so I'm interested if not excited to
see where that guy goes but I do have a
couple of concerns and if I don't
address the concerns in the video I even
make a video if that would be the case
so excited concerned interested me
honestly I just I saw the Joker reveal I
saw Jared Leto Knoller I need to do a
video on that right now so Jared Leto as
the Joker have you seen the bully
obviously you've seen the picture now so
what do you think about it whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you